this is a production of cornell
university
thank you thank you very much and thank
you for allowing us this time too to get
out the information about spotted
lanternfly we really appreciate it
uh
yeah judging from what's happened in the
last
three years as we've been
aggressively tracking the spotted
lanternfly i think this year is going to
be a year that everybody's going to know
about it areas that have never seen it
before are going to be exposed to it and
we are just hoping that we can
slow it down slow down the advance keep
uh
keep an eye on it and know exactly where
it's going to prepare people because
it's it's showing up in areas uh as we
go through you'll see some of the areas
that we did not expect it and it does
show up
and once you see the map of where it is
in new york state you'll understand why
i would say that
it's a little bit of
history on it
as with emerald ash borer asian longhorn
beetle and a number of other
invasive species that have hit the north
america north american continent
this is native to asia china vietnam
that that whole area
the part that is really
frightening about spotted lanternfly it
feeds on over 70 species
we have seen in the nymph stage they
will
feed on anything uh last year in
orangeburg when we were there when the
nymphs were
emerging and hopping around they were
actually feeding on poison ivy so
in that particular state they will feed
on any plant that's available to
you know to get them going
the other major concern for new york
state grapes hops and apples
this is something that obviously new
york is very famous for the wine
industry beer
apples so this is another reason why our
agency is getting so involved in this
along with a number of other agencies
you'll see a lot of reference to the
that preferred host is the ailanthus the
tree of heaven
it needs
doesn't need it to complete its life
cycle but the
tree of heaven is their desired host
because if there's something that is
still researching in it
if it doesn't feed on the tree of heaven
uh the insect is not as robust it
doesn't it's uh it doesn't last as long
it may not
be able to survive in the cooler weather
price it's uh laying eggs but tree of
heaven is the major host that we have
seen
it's life cycle starts has eight masses
and i'll show you some close-ups of egg
messes later because that's the
important thing to look for at this time
of year
you're late in the fall
and preferred hostess tree of heaven but
you'll see when i show you some slides
later
it will lay its eggs on any
stationary object if it's not moving
it'll lay an egg mess on you the in the
new jersey
ppq and state inspectors on the spot
atlantic fly program they act said it
and i believe it wasn't a joke if you
stood still long enough in an infested
area the insect would land on you and
lay eggs on you
i've seen them they're not afraid to
jump on people
the insects are harmless to humans but
it's something that we're gonna have to
be concerned with later on
late april to early may they hatch out
first of foreign stars they're black
with the white spotting 15 stars when
they developed the red
have the red spots in the red with the
white spots and then as the adults
usually july is when you see the
majority of the adults emerging
there's an another but give you a little
more details eggs are late anywhere
june 2 you know october
straight to uh sort of
june they'll be hatching out
the first then star second third they're
all black and at the early stages
they're confused for other insects we
were getting a lot of reports from
where they were first
very numerous in new york city in the
brooklyn area
people were sending in all sorts of
insects thinking it was this and it was
not but when they reach the fourth
instar with the red markings it becomes
very distinctive
and at that point as people start
realizing okay we have a problem because
this is spot atlanta flying
and you get the adults with the telltale
red on their wings
they
emerge july through december
the egg rain season is september through
december
get the
the research is still going on i know
they're researching a lot as it seems to
be adapting to the colder weather
the us d.a has a lab that one of their
forestry scientists is now doing a study
to see if they are adapting to the
colder weather and are able to move
further north
than they are currently
uh egg-laying season september to
december
that also we came across
um interesting situation last year we
had gone through an area in orangeburg
cleared out all the egg masses that we
could reach from the ground we use pulse
scrapers we can go up about 20 feet
obviously we cannot get to the tops of
the trees
we cleared out
the second week of december we collect
everything that was at eye level
or that we could reach
we went back in january mid-january just
to do some checking and we found more
egg masses
so some of these some of these adults
they may look like they're dead but
they're actually just sort of in a
dormant stage in december and if the
weather warms up even for a day or two
they're still able to lay eggs in late
december possibly early january
so with
the extended warm weather this may
become more of a problem or as they
adapt to the colder weather it'll become
more of a problem
a little background the initial
landing in the united states in north
america
was in pennsylvania if i remember it was
uh berks county
came in on some international shipment
still not sure if it was stone some type
of cargo on a wood pallet
however that is where it started
this is what the spread is currently
this is uh the updated map from new york
state integrated pest management at
cornell
they updated mid-february and you can
see
from that one initial
detection manifestation it has now
spread to quite a number of states
you see pennsylvania
is it's from east to west there's a
straight line across
virtually the entire state of new jersey
is now interested
you can see here long island now we do
have infestations new york city all the
way out to suffolk county on the east
end
massachusetts sort of central
massachusetts
southern southwestern connecticut
bordering right up against the new york
line and then up the hudson valley
westchester rocklin orange ulster county
in a
hudson valley
then we have broome county antioga
ithaca
and binghamton in new york state
here's the same thing in ohio this is
just a continuation coming from
pennsylvania but there was this one last
year that was really
concerning everybody in indiana and i
don't remember the name of the town but
it was in switzerland county in indiana
right across
ohio kentucky
it was found in an rv
lot uh rv area where people just block
you know it's that so
we don't know where they don't know
where it came from they're still trying
to trace but obviously came from
somewhere else it was on an rv which is
one of our concerns they're traveling
from different states passing through
infested areas
carrying the insect and you'll see again
further on hitchhiking's
the major way this insect is spreading
itself throughout the country
and you can see maryland
virginia west virginia it is a problem
for a lot of the states now on the in
the northeast and it's spreading west
and south
you see that the purple dots on some of
these
counties these are areas where we have
found adults
but we have not found a full infestation
so it has traveled throughout new york
state and we have found it but we have
not found any further infestations in
these counties same thing here
massachusetts
connecticut
so we may find one or two in
cargo freight uh package that was
delivered to a box store or
we actually had a homeowner call us
they were camping in pennsylvania
when they they drove back to new york
state when they got out of their car
they saw a spot atlanta fly
on on their windshield they were managed
to kill it
but it did transport into one of the
fact i think that was one of these
counties close to the pennsylvania line
okay and you could also see the concern
that we have and you'll see in some of
the other maps that i have
this is the new york state border
between new jersey and pennsylvania so
it's coming right across expanding right
into these areas
these areas in pennsylvania they've had
some discoveries but not a major
infestation
it's a concern because again it's such a
long border with pennsylvania it could
be anywhere and may come across at any
time
okay these these are the current
large infestations manifestations in new
york state
start in south in
the downtown uh downstate metropolitan
area
all of new york city is considered
infested staten island uh which is
richmond county brooklyn which is kings
county queens manhattan and the bronx
they are in fact we have found egg
masses and adults so full life cycle in
all of those counties
nassau county
and is right along the nassau suffolk
county
boundary
we have two major infestations
the scary part about this one is
the northern truck route out into
the farm country and the vineyards is uh
495 interstate 495 long island
expressway there's also a power line
right of way right next to that
and to date we have found over 7 000 egg
masses on that one area
so this is going to be a problem this
summer we know that we're preparing for
that
further out closer to the farm area
that there's the infestation in the uh
excuse me i slipped macarthur airport
area in bohemia
about 30 35 miles away from the
vineyards that's another area where our
concern is it's getting to the farm
country getting to the vineyards we're
going to be spending a lot of time in
that area
moving further up in the hudson valley
right here is that same one where
right at the new york connecticut state
line
here we have orangeburg in rockland
county
slotsburg and rockland county
uh the slothsburg one was on the freeway
in the rest area
and if you ever pull into that area on
uh 87 north the freeway all the trucks
park along one side along the tree line
right along the tree line is where we
found the infestation so we know in this
case it will move by interstate track
into interstate traffic interstate
trucking
you can see here
i-95
i-87
287 goes across here
coming out of new jersey
coming into new york 84 coming out of
massachusetts connecticut into new york
into pennsylvania
it's following a lot of these major
roadways so we know that that's how it's
being
transferred and transported
the areas up here this is in newburgh
i have another slide that will show you
the detail it's
another truck stop
then we know how it got to newburgh
a little further up highland in ulster
county we have found adults
but so far no egg masses
but still looking it's an area of
concern but
we're wondering where these egg masses
are if there are adults there we know
they're egg masses we just haven't found
them yet
further down here is port jervis
port jervis is unique and that's at it's
right at
the intersection where new jersey new
york and pennsylvania meet and
interstate 84 goes right through
we found a number of infestations in
turfs going on now this is going on over
two years
so that is an area another area of
concern
this is the most recent one we found and
one we have been working on a lot lately
we just had
for two weeks we had about 12 to 15
inspectors coming through the binghamton
area checking on that infestation
and unfortunately we have
discovered and scraped about 4 000 egg
masses so far
which if we scrapes four thousand if you
listen to the the researchers they say
we can only reach maybe 35 percent of
the egg masses
that means there's quite a number of
them that we can't reach or find that
are still there
hopefully we can get to them with a
different sort of treatment
the concern again with binghamton it
shows how the transport
of the insect is happening route 81
going north and south right through
binghamton interstate route it also
meets with 88 which goes
northeast
up to the albany area and you have 86 17
feeding into binghamton also with
meeting 81 and 88
major transportation connection
there are truck stops there we also
found it in a truck stop in the
binghamton area
and then we had the ithaca infestation
which
we have managed to control it and that's
the word we're going to be using we can
manage it we can control it we have not
eradicated it we won't say that because
it's it's almost impossible to say it's
eradicated with confidence
you'll see a slide where we did do
treatment in ithaca and we feel
relatively confident that we've slowed
it down whatever we found has been taken
care of and we're hoping we managed to
catch it before it expanded
so
as you can see
major transportation rounds that's what
our concern is
uh one of the areas in port service so i
just wanted to mention there are two
areas and they're both nature trails
huckleberry ridge state forest and
we found
adults and now we're finding egg masses
at the heads
staten island was very similar the k we
figure came over from new jersey to
nature trails
at the parking lots is where we found
the insects
ithaca it was found right at the edge of
cornell's campus and there was a student
parking lot
i was standing in the parking lot
and saw 16 different states represented
by the cars that were parked there
that insect came from somewhere else
people don't know
that it just as you see later again it
can hide the egg messes are difficult to
find
egg masses and adults can be transported
without the
person the truck the train they don't
know
then
this just again to show the major
concern where ag and markets were
concerning the grapes the apples just
the wine industry alone is gonna
be really concerned about because of
what it has done in pennsylvania so
that's another reason we're getting all
this information out and trying to make
sure that we know where it isn't
happening and unfortunately
as you can see the wine areas on long
island
we've found it about 30 miles away from
that it's a large area at the hudson
valley poughkeepsie right across from
there
is the
highland area where we found that on the
nature trail 84th is
newburgh
that's another area we found it and the
concern is goes right up to albany
and of course finger lakes region
central to western new york the farms
the vineyards orchards
this is an area of concern which is why
we are taking such a
deep interest in that binghamton
infestation we don't want it to spread
further north and west
okay the concern
this financial impact
we
want to make sure the vineyards are
ready for this they have all the
information that they need uh any other
farms because then at the larval stage
they will feed on any type of plant at
that point
new york state financially it would be a
big hit if we lost
even a portion of
the vineyards for this industry
the visitors bring a lot of money
they stay over again we love the tourist
tourism industry the workers in the
vineyards uh the impact on that
investors
the producers so it is something of a
major concern
and then as we said the sad part is goes
right up interstate route the north way
the new york state thruway 90 going west
81 going north south 390 coming out of
the wine area
some of these these are some of the the
photos
showing
how it can happen and
these are not necessarily extreme
instances in pennsylvania but these are
the
what they try to educate people to show
them what could happen and we hope it
doesn't get to this point in new york
state they swarm
uh you virtually can't see that the bark
of the tree because there's so many of
them in the thousands
they do produce
honeydew
and it's
produces that black sticky sweet
substance and it
covers steps it'll cover landscaping
trees that will attract wasps on its
bees so it's a secondary problem there
the other problem with the honeydew
in areas
such as vineyards and uh orchards
the honeydew gets all over the leaves
and it appears with photosynthesis
weakening whichever tree or plant that
it's on so that is another concern to
keep them off the trees and keep them
off their uh whatever plant they're
feeding on
this is another it's not really an
extreme there are a lot of homeowners in
pennsylvania and new jersey they're
getting their shop vacs out to get the
insects off the trees that's a harmless
way to the environment
they can do it great
we actually have handheld vacuums that
we go out when they're in the
first through fourth and fifth
installers we use a little handheld
vacuums to
pick up whatever we can find when they
are on the smaller stage when they're
larger we use a vacuum also
or we just
use nets whatever we can to kill him
maybe one day we can get uh
independently powered shot facts to
bring out with us but this is not an
exaggeration this is what people are
doing to control it in their landscape
you can see when they swarm feed they
it's they cover the tree
another example how they form a business
in philadelphia
all around the business story it's of
extreme nuisance to people
not harmful but the nuisance factor is
something that we try to keep in mind
and this was
2019 when it got into philadelphia and
pennsylvania
the population really i guess they
weren't prepared for it it snuck up on
them they were actually calling 9-1-1
reporting severe infestations to the
police
the philly police department you know
they had a interesting sense of humor
saying don't call them but they would
also like to welcome the new insect
overlords
they're from what i've seen in some of
the areas in pennsylvania it's almost as
if they are taking over
but
they're also
subject to treatment and controls and
sometimes it's good sometimes it's bad
the homeowners
this year have been this past year
excuse me 2021 i'm saying it wasn't as
bad as last year
whether they're not going back to the
same areas or
the steps that they are taking to
control the population and working
we're not 100 sure
but we're hoping that keeps up that
means whatever we're doing is helping to
reduce the population even though we may
not eradicate it we can keep it at
controllable levels
this is the main host that they
seem to they require to be strong and
healthy like i said it they can
survive and
complete their life cycle without it but
the insect isn't as strong and as hearty
it may not survive
long enough to produce eggs or may not
produce viable eggs
but the tree of heaven is required it
seems to be around every
major infestation
and part of the reason for that is if
you're familiar with these trees the
atlantis it's a weed tree
it grows anywhere in urban areas you'll
see it growing out of cracks in the
sidewalk
you know i've seen them in new york city
growing between buildings there's a half
a half a foot of space and they'll grow
straight up and over the roofs
anyway it can set down roots it'll grow
and
this is also one of those
plants one of those trees
you cut it at the ground level it's
going to start sending up sprouts and
it's going to come back so it has to be
killed with an herbicide or yanked out
by its roots
okay this is as i was saying before that
they love they cluster
reason is really unknown but they swarm
and they cross the one and they feed at
times
and this is in the vineyards in
pennsylvania which is the example to
show what can happen
you can see the virginia was completely
wiped out by spotted land supply
now it's divine
it's not that they directly kill the
vines it's as they feed on the vines and
they're sucking
uh to sap the juices out of it
it weakens the vines and the vines can't
survive the winter
so it's
not so much that they are killing the
vines as they feed is that they're
reducing the hardiness of the vines
and
as this photo will show
and by springtime they're so weak that
they just
they cannot survive
again this form feeding
they're constantly clustering
it feeds
insect feeds on the sap of the plant it
has the piercing sucking mouth part that
you can see there
and the
problem that creates the honeydew as we
were saying it excretes the honeydew
which is virtually the sugars
it
the interesting thing about this insect
it doesn't really suck the sap
out of the plant
it uses the
the plants the trees target the interior
pressure of the sap moving to actually
feed on it
so it's pulling a lot of the
foam on it it's looking for from but i
understand the amino acids and nitrogen
and it expels any of the sugary sap
as honeydew sugar water which is why it
attracts
bees
ants if it'll attract every other insect
imaginable i can feed on a sweet
substance
so before though the honeydew
it'll develop a [ __ ] mold
if it's left out there long enough
without being cleaned off and the city
molded on its own then will
eventually kill the plant like the vines
or any other fruit trees that it may be
feeding on
can be annoying
uh
i mean it could be annoying if you're
standing under a group
a large amount of these insects feeding
you could actually see the honeydew
raining down there was
a few areas the one in port service
i was we were catching
we were killing
and trapping about four to five hundred
adults each day
but and if you stood directly under the
tree
the honeydew was actually falling on us
it was kind of
kind of disgusting
but it was part of we knew to expect
that the base of the tree was all black
uh you know the honeydew had just
was just turning into the mold and it
was the ground was black and slippery so
for homeowners if they're on the
homeowner's property
so it's sitting in your backyard
is going to be difficult
if these are around
so you know some homeowners that
kind of
push off the idea that they should be
concerned this is something we have to
remind them of it's going to be a severe
nuisance
for you if you like to sit out back if
you want to go to the park you want to
go
on a trail
uh
the city mold is going to make your
property look ugly it's going to attract
other insects bees and
once if you have children then you're
going to be even more worried
so
okay get back to
what i
continually talk about how
how the insect moves
on its own it can move three to four
miles a year
how did it get from that it's it's been
here 2014. if you figure out three to
four miles a year from that initial
discovery in pennsylvania how did it get
up to massachusetts
uh you know they had a discovery in
vermont how did it get out to ohio
again it's the people moving it we had
the similar problem
with the asian longhorn beetle although
it was easier to control asian long-run
beetle
not that any of this stuff is easy
because it had only
12 host trees that it would survive on
and live on
and the trans was transported with wood
firewood the logging industry
we had more of an idea of where to look
how to control it
you know we would talk to the arborists
the tree care companies
they all knew what to look for
people uh
homeowners to an extent
were advised of it but it was more
it was easier to control as i said
because we can
limit anybody touching
elm
or maple you can't move it out in new
york city you can't move it out of
central long island we had quarantines
for aob
spotted lanternfly
we don't
have specific nobody really moves
atlantis it's a weed tree
i don't know of any landscape or tree
company that's ever received a request
hey i want five atlantis on my landscape
that's not going to happen
unfortunately because the spot atlanta
flies attracted to more than feeds on
more than 70 different species
we got a problem we have to control
everything
we have
a statewide quantity of materials coming
into the state and what it means is any
yeah everything should be inspected
before it enters new york to make sure
they're not moving spotted lanternfly at
any life stage
that is difficult to control because
there's so many ways to get in and out
of new york state we can't have
inspectors at every road we don't have
enough inspectors
on every road
checking vehicles coming out of
pennsylvania ohio or any other state
into new york state
the same goes for the other states they
don't have enough inspectors they cannot
stop every vehicle coming out of new
york state now that we have an
infestation so this is something that
it's more of an outreach more of
education let the public let the
transportation industry know
you need to be more aware of anytime
you're moving
any type of equipment and you're in an
area where there may be spotted
lanternfly
we reach reaching out to
the trucking industry or anybody
like department of transportation you
have construction equipment you're using
it in an area and you're leaving that
area inspect your equipment before you
leave
we're sure that's how a lot of this has
moved
uh and i have photos later these dulcie
egg masses anywhere
it doesn't have to be on trees we found
it on rock we found it on metal signs we
found it underneath
a piece of plywood that was lying on the
ground
probably for a year because it was
starting to deteriorate
uh
founded in wheel wells of vehicles
so it could be anywhere they seem to
like rusty metal
metal of any kind it's flat it's soft
that
they'll like it
okay what we have done we've used
different types of traps initially these
traps were all used for uh
detection
uh we have a map that's coming from to
show you we placed them throughout new
york state and it was just
all this spot atlanta flight here it was
almost always use only as a detection
method
uh spot atlantify when the egg masses
hatch
the insects have a
habit of climbing up the trees
wherever they are they climb up they
like to get to the height they like to
get to the top of the trees so we've
managed
the usda
and the states have managed to develop
trapping methods
uh these are two the top one is called a
circle trap where we have sort of a mesh
that funnels the insects as they walk up
the tree it funnels them
into an area it's this photo doesn't
have it but attached to the top is
either a jar or a plastic bag
the insects climb up
inside the mesh and they get stuck in
the bag or the bottle and then we just
collect it and dispose of it
you may have heard
the sticky tape was being used this was
used a lot in new jersey pennsylvania
and we were using it for a while and
then we also realized that we had to do
something
there was bycatch
and
it was
it was it was sad anyway there were
birds caught squirrels caught on the on
the sticky tape so what we have been
doing
putting a mesh wire around the sticky so
the insects can get up onto the tape but
hopefully this will prevent any birds or
other
animals from getting stuck on it
the mesh that we use in new york is a
little tighter than this
uh because i think even in this one as
birds saw the insects they were sticking
their feet through and getting stuck
but we stopped using
uncovered sticky tape
even though it worked we don't use this
method much anymore
and this is sort of the type of mesh
that we use in new york it's very fine
so nothing can get through it from the
outside but the insects can still crawl
up and as you can see it does catch
quite a bit
what we're using
a lot of now in new york is this called
the bug barrier
it's manufactured by a specific company
the inside
of this band is the sticky part
there's a foam underneath it that goes
right up against the bark of the tree
and because it's foam it seals up all
the unevenness so it's a barrier as the
insects are crawling up they hit this
foam
if they try to crawl back on the outside
they get stuck on the tape
we have had no by-cats using this type
of bug barrier trap it's it's worked
very well
and we we use this also
quite a bit for monitoring
and eventually
next one
eventually we'll be using that for other
purposes for control of the population
here's a closer photo of that
circle trap
you can see how it's sort of a big
funnel as they climb up they're going to
be
gradually funneled into this
little area here
into a bag or jaw whichever we put on
the top
these are the traps that we had deployed
last year
i think we had approximately 250 traps
out statewide last year
okay the orange
dots are mostly us new york state ag
markets and the usda ppq usda is is
working very closely with us we have
partners in the uh this control program
all these green dots were traps that
were put up by
stakeholders uh
other agencies working with us dot put
up a number of traps the prisms have
been very helpful they've put up a lot
of traps
uh new york state parks
has put up traps
and i see
new york state uh state dec and new york
city dep around the reservoir areas that
are putting up traps so we've had a lot
of cooperation
getting traps up throughout
these
are what we used last year and this was
mostly used again for detection this is
how we found those infestations
long island and further upstate
this year we're going to be doing
trapping
uh
not so much for detection we're still
going to use a number of chops for
detection
this year we plan to deploy over 500
close to 700 if we can
manage at 7 750
traps
and we are going to attempt to use it
for population control
the usda is doing a study in
pennsylvania
uh
our traps have caught a lot of insects
this the past summer of 2021.
so we're hoping that if we can saturate
an area where we expect a large
population say binghamton area
uh ithaca
also just in case something else pops up
i'm sorry ithaca and moves further into
the finger lakes we're going to really
concentrate on that area and
the long island area suffolk county the
east end
uh with the usda we'll probably end up
putting
maybe 200 traps just around the long
island area binghamton may end up being
around the same number
but as i was saying the usda has been
doing a study in pennsylvania they
they said the
initial results were promising that
testing to see if it can actually be
reduced the population they have found
good results so far you can
what they are trying to do is work out
how close to each other the traps should
be or how far apart to still be
successful in knocking the population
down
you know it may have to be one every 50
feet one every 100 feet can it be one
every 200 feet
that study is is being performed in
pennsylvania they did part of it late
last summer they're going to do it again
this year
hopefully it'll come out and show that
this is a good method
what i can say is some of the traps that
we had to show you the ones in port
jervis we caught over a thousand in one
trap over the course of two months so
they will knock down
any population which at this point
is a positive for us and that's what
we're attempting to do
okay
another concerning part about this
insect the earlier photos
you see the red wings
and i know if you see in my background i
have a
a print of one of the insects and they
always show the red as being very bright
and vibrant
unfortunately when it's an adult has its
wings folded and it's closed and it's
sitting on the bark of a tree it's very
difficult to find especially if you're
looking maybe 10 12 feet away
you can see there were four on the photo
on the right there were four adults
on there
and if you could see if you can see all
of them and that's the part that really
was a test to us in learning
how to identify this and find this
as you can see there's four
and what we had when our first major
infestation
other than in staten island in the
orangeburg new york area which is in
rockland county right on the new york
new jersey border
we were
new to this
um unfortunately
we were supposed to be training in new
jersey and pennsylvania so we would be
more prepared for this but then covet
hit we couldn't travel interstate
whatever we
could learn we had to learn from photos
and slides and i can tell you firsthand
you're not going to be able to identify
it just from photos and slides it takes
a while to to pick these out
there was a nature trail
in port jarvis right next to a parking
lot so we understand how the insect
nation we got there
we a number of us were looking at the
same tree and it was clean we didn't see
anything
if you stayed there
and watched for maybe 10 minutes
suddenly you would realize there was one
at eye level straight in front of you
but you couldn't tell because it blended
in so well with the tree bark
and that has happened more
times than i would like to admit to a
lot of us
so when we go out we go out with at
least two inspectors checking everything
and have a backup set because
the angle of the sunlight the angle
you're looking at it you could look
straight at it not see it you move half
a foot to the right
and suddenly it's very visible they're
very difficult when they're on the trees
if they're not swarming or clustering
the same thing for egg masses
this is something and we were not
able to actually see egg messes first
hand because of the travel restrictions
because of covid
and there was one stretch in orangeburg
where and i i admitted
we walked past
egg masses at least
five or six times without seeing it
to us the trees were clean we didn't see
anything
when we stopped and if i remember i
think there was six of us we all stood
around one tree and we
just stared at this tree for at least 10
minutes and suddenly
that one tree that we walked by five
times we found over 17 egg masses just
at that one moment
so the adults and egg masters they're
difficult to see you have to look
carefully
uh again if it's cloudy you gotta look
even more carefully when we
inspect
for egg masses or adults
we actually carry flashlights with us
for the daytime
flash inside the canopy because
sometimes the slightest bit of shade you
could miss a lot
uh it's very
difficult to identify these even when
you're trained even some of us now that
we've been
doing this two or three years and seeing
them repeatedly
one inspector can find something that
another inspector walked right by
so
it's not even a matter nobody gets
pinpointed why don't you know how to see
it this insect is very good at
camouflaging itself
okay
the egg masses
you can see they lay the egg masses and
there's usually
30 to 60 they don't have an exact number
30 to 60 egg masses
per egg mass and you can see the rows
are probably about one inch long these
are uncovered
normally they are covered with the
putty-like substance it starts out white
gradually
maybe a little pink brown and it
the color darkens but it it stays there
if it
if the putty mass covering stays there
otherwise
we don't find
a lot the majority are covered
we do find quite a number though that
are uncovered
and this is what overwinters the adults
will not survive the winter
the egg masses
to the best of our knowledge they are
surviving
up to
let's say like you can see it we found
them up the hudson valley
close to albany so maybe even new york
state throughway going east for us route
90 interstate 90.
it's warm enough below that that the egg
masses are surviving the winter
and we don't know
will they survive it hasn't been here
that long it's still only three to four
years in new york state
and there is that
researcher in connecticut for the forest
service she's actually studying how cold
will it be before the egg masses will be
killed but she does believe that they're
adapting to alcohol the mainland further
north and and that's what's scary
we also do
we
go through infested areas and we scrape
as many egg masses as we can i mentioned
earlier we scraped seven over seven
thousand egg masses in long island
approximately four thousand forty five
hundred in the binghamton area
we've
people are mentioning
when you look at the research that says
you can only reach 35 of them the rest
of them are up in the tree canopy and
with manual means we're not going to see
them or reach them why do we bother
if you just do a little bit of math from
what i've told you instead of saying 30
to 60
just take as an example there are 40
viable
eggs for one egg mass that survived the
winter
if that hatches out you're gonna have
uh one egg mess will produce 40 viable
eggs
suddenly they hatch out
if you get 100 of those egg masses
you can have 4 000 adults
and that's just from 100 egg masses and
using a conservative number of 40 eggs
that survive
if half of those are female 2000 female
very late 2000 egg masses
the following year we're now going to
have 80 000 adults
if half of them are female
that means
40 000 egg masses for the following year
and then the adults going to be over a
million
the year after that so when anyone
questions why are we scraping egg masses
it definitely will affect the total
population and if that's one of the ways
we can do to control it that's what we
are doing we're asking everybody to do
at
social media sites uh
dec has a very big presence they're
advertising a lot they're posting a lot
new york state ag markets is also
posting you see egg masses scrape it
destroy it kill it
everyone that you destroy prevents as i
said at least
maybe 100 adults next year
40 anywhere 30 to 60 adults per egg mass
so you are helping the program you are
helping control it again we're not using
the word eradicate because
we're not going to be able to get
everyone we control it we'll be happy
and we also hope that this gives
the researchers enough time to come up
with a better control than we have now
some type of
biological control something unique to
this insect which i know they're working
on i don't have a lot of information on
that but they are working on different
types of fungi that will affect that
uh penn state and cornell are doing a
lot of research they're supplying a lot
of our information
as you can see a lot of the information
i'm showing has come from
uh new york state ipm cornell they've
been an amazing help when it comes to
giving us information and doing the
research um if you're going to hear me
constantly say i appreciate everything
they've done the information they're
giving us is priceless
and this is what i was mentioning
earlier they'll lay egg eggmasters
anywhere if it's stationary they'll end
up laying eggmas on a signpost we found
quite a few of them on signposts
you leave out some personal belongings
of folding chairs and out
in the backyard
suddenly the next day you're going to
see egg mass and it's not just one as
you can see
they're all over
a little more close-up of the young
masses this is what you're going to see
between 30 to 50 so that's why i use the
average of 40.
here you can also see if you're not
looking at tree buck close enough are
you going to be able to tell that this
is an egg mess it takes a while to be
able to
be confident that what you're seeing is
that and how many people are going to
look at a tree see this and know that
it's by blanton fly
that comes to that part we have to
educate the public everybody uh
landscapers farmers vineyard owners
get to know the signs of
what
an eggness looks like over the winter
time
and then eventually once they become
adults it's easier as they're moving
around
easily transported
that this is
personally i feel this is how it got
spread through new york state and
everywhere that we found it
it has a good explanation you can see on
a truck
egg masses where nobody would normally
look
if these were found we had
performed some truck stops as dot would
pull over semis interstate traffic for
safety inspections
they were kind enough to allow us to
inspect for spotted lanternfly and we
were finding them on some of the trucks
coming from other states or coming from
an infested area
and we were finding this
and the driver could walk around his
truck checking to see if the truck is
safe is he going to see this
not looking for that he doesn't know it
those may hatch out in another state
there's another one you can see an adult
caught in the grill
you can see pieces here
what we have done also
the new york new jersey trail conference
uh connected with the lowell hudson
valley prison has
conservation dogs
have two dogs uh dia and fagin which are
trained
to sniff out all stages of spotted
lanternfly and if i remember correctly
it was a situation similar to this at
one of our truck stops where they found
the remains of an adult in the grill of
a truck
but we have used those conservation dogs
to sniffer dogs
to find egg masses and adults in areas
where we didn't know it was but we
thought it had expanded
and the dogs were amazing
they found
egg masses in an area that we had gone
through that we were not aware were
there so the the uh
they play an important part in what we
do we
use them they
are limited and we're limited in the
amount of time they can spend with us
but when we do use them
it's uh remarkable how
how good they are i mean you see the
stories and hear the stories and see the
examples about these sniffer dogs for
all the types of insects but
it was just amazing watching them go to
an area that we had inspected and pull
up two or three more egg masses that we
had not noticed they were so well hidden
but the dogs knew where to go and where
to find it
and fence posts
uh we not only do we use flashlights we
have mirrors
uh that we can look under vehicles the
other
we have to use them in we first realized
that in orangeburg
there was a nature trail with a railing
going
over a pedestrian bridge
underneath
the bottom rail
like
two or three inches above ground level
underneath we found over 16 egg masses
on one railing
so now we're going around with mirrors
checking under everything behind
uh fences if we can't physically get
behind a fence
the egg masses are appearing everywhere
we use it
we have to look at every card rails
we have to look on both sides and
underneath we go along the highways
check for that
uh this is an another case
trees that were overloaded with vines
we pulled away some of the vines and we
found masses
uh quite a few egg masses underneath the
vines the adults got in there it was a
hidden area protected
they laid their eggs if we didn't pull
away the vines we would not have seen
them
this is another reason why it's very
difficult to see them all because even
pulling off all those vines on that one
tree how many of them could we get to or
we can be able we couldn't get all the
way up 40 50 feet if the vines went up
that high i'm sure there was some ignis
up there that
we as ground inspectors couldn't get to
another concern these are photos you can
see the credits
one of our usda partners
just pulled away some loose bark and
found underneath hidden inside the
crevice their egg masses
we found quite a few of these in the
binghamton area on actually dead trees
where the block was kind of just inching
away from the tree itself
and
i'd say it out of the thousand to few
thousands that they caught
at least 100 to 200 white in areas
similar to this
hidden behind bark of a tree either
dying or a wound in a tree or just
subtype of a crevice in the tree
this is the part where we know
this is what's going to get by a lot of
people we have to
education look very carefully look
everywhere for the egg masses
and what we do and what we advise the
public or anybody working on spotted
land supply to do
if if you can't
crush it and you know if you scrape it
off and falls on the ground stomp on it
crush it make sure
it is you know destroyed
the laboratories the usda lab has told
us that we had asked them about
we used pole scrapers and we were
concerned some of when we scraped the
egg mess
off the tree it may fall into an area we
can't reach to step on
and we ask them is there a possibility
that they might survive not being
attached to a tree or a surface
and the answer unfortunately was yes
there's a good possibility if you scrape
it off the tree and the egg masses the
eggs themselves aren't crushed
they may still hatch out wherever they
landed
so what we try to do with the pole
scrapers is
crush it against the tree first and then
scrape it so that we feel a little more
confident that there's no chance there's
a viable egg still there
the lower ones will scrape them off
you can use a card
uh like a credit card
uh we have again we use our own scrapers
we scrape them into plastic bags or
large mouth bottles that have some
alcohol or will we tell it again the
public we tell them you can use some
hand sanitizer in a plastic bag if you
don't have alcohol readily available
scrape it in there let them soak the
alcohol will kill them
this was the uh infestation we had in
ithaca
and this is closest the closest one we
had prior to binghamton to the finger
lakes region and
we consider this
we have
a good idea of what's going on in good
control
it happened right at the edge of
cornell's campus the university campus
and there was two wood lots but in an
area where there was uh
i guess student housing there were
private apartments some student housing
and we were very
lucky in this area
uh the
ithaca forestry department
their chief chief forrester was amazing
when we she showed us we showed her
where this was what was being done what
may have needed to be done
and the forestry department was
extremely cooperative they worked with
us we got permission from the property
owners
so as you can see we did
we removed the atlantis we moved some
other hospices at the same time
i think in a way the property owners
were kind of happy because we got rid of
a weedy area in an overgrown area so now
they it's easier for them to keep it
cleaner and uh
looking a little better because it was
quite it was quite overgrown and it did
have uh
some
really uh burrs and the vegetation
wasn't exactly pleasing
so
after we did the clear cut of the two
areas we found no other signs i think
there was a report that they found one
nymph somewhere so there may be an egg
mass missed but we have found nothing
since
so we are keeping a close eye on ithaca
and this one area and it is
kind of an isolated area as you'll see
on a map that i have coming up
but this was reconsiders one of the
success stories where everybody the
public and
the municipal agencies and the state
agencies we all worked together and were
able to come up with a good solution to
this that that worked
the
contractor that did the removals also
came in and did a spring after
we did the clear cut of uh
i think was by fentren
but that was just
sort of a little bit more insurance that
we caught everything
unfortunately it's not going to be that
easy to get permission from everybody
hey we want to remove your bunch of your
trees it becomes expensive sometimes
homeowners
landowners they don't want the trees
removed
so we have to come up with alternative
types of treatment but so far we've had
uh
good luck on this and i hope this
continues in other areas
yeah the treatment
what we can do
the maths that are coming up and show
you this what we do is
wherever there is a positive find we
know there's an infestation and it has
the life cycle of the insect you know
egg mass
and
uh adults
what we do is we do an intensive survey
for a quarter of a mile around it
okay we identify everything and then
what we do is
we'll go out
another quarter of a mile so it'll be a
total of a half a mile from the
positives and in that second quarter
mile half mile buffer
if we find it clean which is what
happened in ithaca then we feel that
okay
there's a good chance we've isolated the
infestation and we will treat within
that quarter mile ring because that's
where it is
we went around an extra quarter of a
mile and we didn't find anything we
it's uh
we've used that formula on other insects
and it seems to have worked so we're
using it for this also and as i said
ithaca seems to have worked we're
currently putting that in
the binghamton area and you'll see from
the maps every other area we're doing
that
the tree all of the atlantis the
atlantis of the ones that we will treat
within that quarter mile ring will be
treated
we dinotefuran is the pesticide of
choice
any atlantis above six inch dbh will be
used with dinotefune it's about the
basal box spray
so basically you know six seven feet
five feet from the ground
you know the root flare all the way up
is sprayed
the insects feed on it it becomes
systemic the insects feed on it they
drop they die right usually right there
atlantis under six inches
like it to be removed uh the problem
with that as i said before if they cut
it just cut it at ground level it's
going to sprout
and the insect likes fresh new
sprouts of ailanthus i guess that's
the term they use it's like candy to
them you'll see them go after the
atlantic sprouts because it's fresh and
it's
new uh otherwise they will use a hack
and square which just means they wound
the tree at the base
to spray
uh herbicide in it and kill it that way
which is
yes there's one way better than the
other hack and square we know it's not
going to send up sprouts every three
hope it's not but that's probably not
going to happen
so removal or hacking square get rid of
the ones on the six inch that's all done
within the quarter mile
in new york what we've done
it's not just ag markets
working on this there is no way one
agency could handle this and
the director of ag markets realized this
initially right on and started this
multi-agency approach which is really
working extremely well with us
to the point where some other states
have asked for the model how did you do
this
and you know how does it work because
they're trying to get in on us because
again markets alone cannot handle this
the ec alone could not handle its dot
alone could not handle this because it's
so spread out over the state now and it
could appear anywhere at any time
uh if you can see from the slide on
major cooperators the usda ppq they're
constantly by our side working with us
dec
as you all know they're very aware of
any of the invasives working very
closely with us working side by side
we're very lucky in that new york state
d.o.t has taken an active role in this
they are setting our traps they're
monitoring their plans for it and
working with us
uh
new york state parks also
they're working hand-in-hand with us
they're checking all their properties
setting out traps monitoring it
and uh
new york city dep because they have
their reservoirs
throughout the uh
hudson valley they have their people
looking for us they are setting traps
and monitoring
new york city parks new york city eot
they have their own set of problems but
they are also part of this whole agency
so we all know what's going on
and as the second bullet point points
out
we're using the same data collection
to work the technical words platforms we
survey one two three and workforce so
all our data comes in and we can put it
on one map
the usda can see what we're doing we can
see what dec is doing dec can see what
dot is doing dot you can see what
usda is doing
we know
by looking at all this we're not
stepping on each other's toes and we're
getting better coverage
we know
again markets we know dot has a
residence in this area we know we don't
have to spend as much time there as we
normally would we know dot is looking
for us looking for themselves
ppq and us they work with us so they're
taking a certain area
but we can look at the map
state is here or dot is here oh dep has
traps in this area
we don't have to put more traps there
let's move somewhere else
we are also using prisms
you heard me you've heard me mention
very quickly before the prisms have been
an incredible help to us
they are getting the word out their
people are looking they're gathering
data
the lower hudson valley uh put out traps
uh i think the finger lakes prism also
was putting out traps putting out fires
the social media reach it's just been
incredible how they're getting the word
out and reporting what they find to us
uh i
since most of the initial area was
downstate most of my experience has been
with the lower hudson valley prison but
i've been
making contact with the other prisons
and i it's like i said the cooperation
we're getting for them is great
if you have to reach out to them they
have a lot of information available
uh and they're very helpful
the other thing that is good about the
multi-agency approach
we may not have all the equipment we
need and it's coming up to the point
where we're looking
for treatment for some of the egg masses
this year
again markets may not have i know we
don't have a lot of the equipment that
we would need to do all the areas
but usda does or dot does dec does so
we're pooling our equipment to do the
treatment so
we don't have to go out and get all this
equipment dec doesn't have to buy all
the equipment we're pulling the
equipment we know what we have
if we need
missed sprayers or cannon sprayers we
can call ppq or dec whoever happens to
have it at that time
so this is something that as i said the
director of our
division
initiated uh
two two and a half years ago and
i don't think we would have been as
successful even in just the monitoring
stage if it wasn't for this
so all these state agencies and the
prisons that have been cooperating with
us have led to the point where we got
all this information and
we're hoping that this will give us
enough to slow the events
and i'm not going to say we're going to
eradicate it right now we just have to
slow it as much as we can and control
the population and hope the researchers
catch up with some type of control that
would that will hold it back
uh citizen scientists we're using imap
invasives asking the public
take these classes you know report where
you see atlantis report where you see
any any of the insects
and
just let us know we have access to this
so as the public reports it we can look
in imap invasives and see okay we got a
positive report here let's send somebody
out to verify is it true and then
we can do what we have to do as far as
control uh
treatment of any sort again i mentioned
prisms
i can't say enough about the prisons
they've been so helpful to us without
them
we said we wouldn't be as far as we have
along with the the multi-agency approach
so what we we have used the prisons for
is uh
they're another set of eyes and ears you
saw vast areas where there were no traps
on that map they're able to check that
and help us and say okay yeah it's it's
okay you don't have to go here we just
checked this whole woodlot we checked at
this park we just checked the city
so
that's something that we did not have
the personnel to do so it is
a great help
and i keep saying that but i i can't say
enough for that
extensive ground surveys i said we just
spent two weeks in the binghamton area
at 12 inspectors 12 to 15 inspectors
we were able to see from the ground up
unfortunately there was snow and ice
cover on the ground so we weren't able
to see everything that was on the ground
the root flares there was some
any type of
back if we were in private properties
backyard properties toys and landscaping
were covered with snow and i assumed
where we could expect eggman we were
unable to see under percent but we were
able to see what was on the trees and
that's the scary part in binghamton
most of the egg masses we found were
visible on the trees because the ground
had snow cover and if we found 4 000
at eye level
we know we got to go back
you know so what's the snow cover and
the ice cover is gone we're gonna have
to go back and go over some of these
properties and see what we weren't able
to see down below
secure treatment releases
we're going to go through again and
that's the homeowners and the property
owners public or private
would you be willing to allow
us or dec or ppq come in and do some
type of treatment
whether uh it's with the dinotefuran
atlantis removal
atlantis hack and squirt or uh there's
another one i didn't mention and it's
not listed here the golden test oil
spray which is used on egg masses and
they're talking about that a lot so
we are thinking of doing that we are
preparing to do that it depends on
where government agency it depends a lot
on our funding
uh but we are working on that now
deciding
if we have the funding to do it can we
do it where are we going to do we're
preparing
to actually perform this treatment with
the uh the spray oils for the egg masses
we need to secure releases permissions
from the property owners so when we go
back to finish our inspections we're
going to be asking them to sign a
releasing
we can treat your property explain to
them what it is giving them more
information
and hopefully we get enough
cooperation from property owners that we
can actually do the treatment
now our concern is
uh i stay in contact we stay in contact
a lot with our new jersey counterparts
one or two of the problems they've had
is you can go an entire and i'll use the
term block because it's in the
residential areas
you can get out of 25 houses on the
block you can get permission to treat
21.
where everybody's concerned well if
there are egg masses on those other four
that didn't sign
wow is it even worth it
as i mentioned before
every egg mess that we scrape off is
potentially preventing 40 adults so
okay we have to live with it we're still
knocking back the population by at least
a half to 75
we consider that a victory
so we're hoping that we get
cooperation from the public on this and
like i said that'll be coming up within
the next month or so uh once we get back
once the snow cover is gone
then this is virtually just repeating
the multi-agency approach the traps i
mentioned the new method of using traps
this year we plan on doing it as
population control not just detection
it will be a combination of both
detection and control population control
the management plan is based on they
have this matrix of how to decide which
areas to go through
uh the financial impact the people
impact uh the impact on the crops itself
so that that'll tell us where we're
gonna
put our intensive efforts
yeah i mentioned before right now it
looks like
the hudson valley
the east end of long island the
vineyards and the farmland out there
and finger lakes region western new york
yeah vineyards farms orchards that's our
concern so as that's what aggregate
markets is going to be focusing on and
we use our little decision matrix to say
okay where do we start when do we start
how much
effort do we do here versus here
uh we are not saying that we're giving
up on
homeowners or other areas
but we you know we have to protect the
crops egg and markets that's our mission
we're using the outreach to get the
people to understand what they can do on
their own
and
the next
but we're not up at that page yet just
to give you an idea again i was talking
about the quarter mile half mile
the pink shaded areas are the quarter
mile circles the yellow is the half mile
this is binghamton
now you can see if
it's half mile from the center of an
infestation
to the outer rim of the second buffer
zone so when you look at this whole area
we have almost four miles
that we're trying to inspect and you can
just imagine this is a residential area
on the left here a lot of houses a lot
of properties
in two weeks it took us a lot just to
get through
maybe half of it
it's a big job but the other thing to
notice is
this road coming in from the right is
8617.
this road current from the south is 81.
so 81 and 17 major
highway a 17 is also interstate 86
right through binghamton then 86
continues west 81 continues north
the other point of concern is
if you look closely enough on this map
this is a railroad line
no [ __ ] southern is going right
through here and there are there's got
to be at least 30 sightings here
every time we've been up there there had
to be hundreds of freight
cars just sitting waiting to be moved
where did it come from did it come from
an infested area in pennsylvania
virginia
is it being infested are the cars parked
there now being affected by the current
infestation we have in binghamton and
those freight cars will now transfer it
further western new york potentially
into another state
so that's again this is a concern why
we're concerned with the binghamton area
this is ithaca i was saying before
ithaca we only had that one
infested area
we were able to go through that whole
quarter mile area nothing has nothing
else has been found nothing is pounding
a half mile area we're monitoring it
they were talking about possibly doing a
treatment just as a second treatment
this year
we haven't found egg masses so it may
not be an eggness treatment we may do a
dinotefuran spray
later on in the spring
and hopefully we don't see any hatch out
but that is something we are watching
closely this is an area where we feel
our efforts did come up with a positive
resolution we're not going to say it was
eradicated
but it seems like we've halted the
spread of it further into the finger
lakes area so we're considering this
a good example of what we want to do
this is the point jervis area and i'm
just want to use this to show you one of
the incidents that's happening that's
confusing a lot of people
this is route 84 that comes out of
massachusetts connecticut across new
york state
right into pennsylvania and what i was
mentioning earlier the area of concern
this is where new jersey pennsylvania
and new york state all meet and
it's really no surprise that that's
where we're finding infestation
the interesting part about this that's
confusing us in this area here
in 2020 we found one egg mass
2021
we killed well over 2 000 adults
in that same area where we found the egg
mass and we don't where did these adults
come from we did a thorough search we
only found one egg mess
gives you
the idea of how difficult it is to
control this insect where did all those
other eggmans where were they hiding
so you know we had
four inspectors there for weeks trying
to look under everything
suddenly all the adults showed up
the strange part is the opposite
happened further down in the city area
in one of their parks
we had found a lot of egg masses and we
scraped them
you know what we could find but we knew
there was still some there
and there were very few adults
not as many as we would have expected
from the egg messes we scraped so there
are still things the researchers are
studying the scientists are studying we
don't know the answer to
but we're hoping
we're knocking down the population
hopefully they'll come up with a result
uh these areas here
along route 6 84. this is some of those
areas where i was saying there were
nature trails at each one of these fines
and each time we found either an adult
or an egg mass was in the parking area
the trailhead
so it's it was got it moved there by
people cars
any type of uh vehicle they used to get
to that area
we think dec is clearing that area
checking that area we think we may have
controlled it because further in
you don't find that many atlantis in a
forest usually find that at the edges at
disturbed areas which is why you see
them in parking lots around railroads
around highways
but that's another area of interest that
we're going to be working on
frank it's three o'clock so we are going
to need to start wrapping up okay okay
uh again
newberg are concerned these are infested
areas show you a little long island this
is the area where we're concerned 30
miles further east are the farms and the
vineyards we're going to the usda in new
york state this is where we're going to
make a stand with treatment and trapping
the lower hudson valley you can see
these are all the fines so our concern
is there
and this if you need any information
the integrated pest management cornell's
ipm website is fantastic anything you
need is here you want general
information it's here
insecticides
you need your homeowner or business you
got hormone or commercial use the list
is here if anything that's
usable acceptable that'll work
uh just go to this website and you'll
find anything you need see insecticides
for use on spotted random fly fact
sheets
tons of information
then if you're in a quarantine zone
you're leaving you're driving through
check your vehicle check anything
we ourselves if inspectors as we were
leaving being attended we checked
everything on our cars we checked the
wheel wells we checked under the hood
making sure we weren't transporting
anything out although this time of year
we know egg masses weren't being laid
we're just being extra careful
we do that during
the flying season when they are laying
eggs every vehicle is checked before it
leaves an area that we're working in
we ask anybody to report it
on the ipm website there's a way to
report it there's an email address for
new york state which is spotted
lanternfly at
agriculture.ny.gov you can report it
there
every report is going to be looked at
and that the timing is good i actually
got to the end
yeah i keep saying that cornell new york
state ipm
national of ipm for a lot of this
information thank you
thank them for all this data all the
help that they've been providing us uh
like you can't put a price on it it's
been invaluable information to help us
through this help us with the outreach
to the public
and here's the time if you have any
questions i guess that can be i can try
to answer them
and just if anybody wants here's my
contact information and ethan angel
who's the field manager for the entire
state
his contact information
feel free to call me email me
request any type of information if i can
help you out with information or any
type of
outreach material we'd more than happy
to uh any more people involved in this
we appreciate that
so i've
hear any questions that uh
any questions for frank you could either
ask or you could put it over in the chat
i put the ipm uh websites that frank had
mentioned they're in the chat as well if
you'd like to go there
okay okay i guess
so i don't see anything in chat um kim
if you want to put the
the uh
you already did you put out the checkout
link for the dec credits frank i really
want to thank you this was an excellent
presentation and one of the scariest
presentations i think i've heard in my
career
yeah
it could be and i guess the whole point
is we want to get the public aware of
what's coming
uh as i said it encroached on new york
city faster than we had
expected so we want to warn everybody
but yeah i thank you for this
opportunity to
get the word out to more people
especially up in the western area of new
york which we haven't had that bigger
presence until recently so again thank
you very much for allowing us this time
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu